hearing the MVP chance from the crowd
throughout the
game uh we need to finish this game like
I'm I'm not really paying attention to
the to the chance you know um last year
um we was the score was looking like
that you know halftime and stuff like
that in third quarter then those guys
start making plays and we didn't do
anything you know but all the only thing
was on my mind was to finish the game
and today we did it Mar how do you
balance the excitement over what you
guys accomplished with knowing that you
still have a lot that you want to get
done knowing that we still have a lot to
get um going on you know we uh got to
finish this season the right way uh we
had one obstacle we finished that
obstacle um we got Steelers next week
you know so that's how I'm that's how
I'm staying focused this season just
taking one game at a time like I've been
preaching to you guys all season how
important was it to how important was it
to you know win this game
get the top seed you know the road of
the Super Bowl runs through you know
Baltimore obviously how important was it
to get it today uh it was very important
you know we had a lot of guys you know
banged up you know um nipped up with
injuries guys who couldn't play um we
had guys who stepped up uh knew the
situation and they played lights out you
know um All Phases um we all knew it was
important for us to get this win and and
we did just that you clinch the number
one back in 2019 does it feel any
different today clinching it this you
know how you did it compared to to when
you clinched it in 2019 at all uh the
only difference is I'm
older that's the only difference and um
different guys who's a part of this team
now so that's the only
difference